this is from the independent
says tucker carlson has some unique
advice for his young male fans drop out
of college and have more children than
you can afford
the popular but controversial fox news
host himself a bow tie wearing product
of boarding schools debate societies and
a liberal arts college made the comments
on sunday during the interview carlson
and host daniel schmidt a student at the
university of chicago bonded over what
the youtube host called a pervasive
amount of anti-white sentiment okay so
this is just a hit piece bouncing all
over the place uh that doesn't matter
what does matter is this clip which has
made the rounds online and there are
people that are upset about it as well
because carlson said it which means
people are upset about it but let's
listen to the advice that he gives go
ahead
achievement comes through commitment and
responsibility so my advice to young
people particularly young men
is just dive face-first into it like
drop out of college college is
ridiculous unless you're moving towards
some very specialized degree that you
can only get in college if you want to
be a veterinarian or a physicist or
something but if you're in humanities
you know i can give you a list of 100
books you can find it on the internet
and you'll be better educated than you
would be at whatever stupid college you
go to a b
get married
and you know
choose wisely but don't overthink it
you know don't overthink it people
overthink it like if you're compatible
with someone
and you can smell that
you can make it work and by the way it's
never easy because men and women
fundamentally don't understand each
other that's the whole joy in it that's
why marriage makes you grow
is because you don't really understand
the other person so you have to try
every day
to decipher what that person's saying
have more children than you can afford
take a job you're not qualified for
like go balls out
you just go balls out i don't know what
is everyone waiting for you know have
some adventure in your life do something
crazy i mean it and and i don't mean you
know go to bali skip bali please
uh well of course people are upset about
the what he says there the insight he
provides because it's true right and if
you provide true insight into life
you're always going to upset people
these days
does it make sense that the same company
who controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home what about the
idea that a single company controls 90
of internet searches runs your email
service and gets to track everything you
do on your smartphone big tech is more
powerful than most countries are and
they profit by exploiting your personal
data it's time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and big tech and that's why i use
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet sadly every site
you visit video you watch message you
send gets tracked and data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something bigtech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn makes your
activity harder to trace and also harder
to sell to advertisers expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your net internet data
to keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers on your network what i
like most about expressvpn is how easy
it is to use you just download the app
on your phone or computer tap one button
and that's it you're protected and
expressvpn does all of this without
slowing your connection either that's
why it's rated the number one vpn
service by techradar the verge and
countless others so stop handing over
your personal data to the big tech
monopoly who minds your activity and
sells your information protect yourself
with the vpn that i trust to keep me
safe online visit
expressvpn.comwalshyt to get three extra
months free he touches on a couple of
things there that are really important
one one the one that he says you know
don't overthink it
when it comes to marriage and this is
something this is a drum that i've been
beating for years
um and he's exactly right about that
and if you listen to people who are
actually married and have been married
successfully and are in happy marriages
you're all this is this is this is you
know there's wide agreement among
actually married people
um it's only people that aren't married
that are scandalized by this kind of
thing that should tell you something
because it doesn't mean that you know
you meet someone
and you kind of like them so you get
married the next day okay no one's
saying that we'll run off to las vegas
and get married in a drive-through
wedding after one day no one is saying
that but if you if you beat them
and uh you like them and you're
attracted to them
and you're compatible
and also you you note that you have
you know your your fundamental values
align
which is something that you can discover
about someone early on by actually like
talking to them if you have real
conversations with them rather than
inane small talk all the time you can
discover all of that very quickly
and um
then at that point like what what else
is there to wait for what are you
waiting around i mean you can see these
days people think well
okay i'm attracted to them i like them
we get along we're compatible
we have our fundamental values do a line
uh but
we need to date for 17 years you know
and we got to move in together and
because we have to know every last
detail about this person what if they
have what if there are things about them
that annoy me
right i got to find that out first no
you don't need to find it out because
i'll tell you the answer right now there
are there are a ton of things that annoy
you about that because they're a per
they're another person they're a whole
other human being and so they're you're
not going to be compatibility is not
going to be 100
there are going to be difficulties
you're going to be bumping up against
each other on various different topics
all the time that's just part of living
with someone you work through that
that's part of marriage
and the thing is it doesn't even matter
like
you can spend years with someone getting
to know every last detail about them
and uh and then you say okay we're ready
to get married and you get married well
you still gotta start
right eventually you're gonna have your
first day of marriage
it doesn't matter how much time you
spent with them ahead of time
once you get married you're you're
you're married now the game changes
you're a rookie i don't care if you knew
that person for 15 years ahead of time
you're basically in the same boat as
someone who knew their spouse for
15 minutes because now you're starting
at square one you've got to start in
square one
and you have your first day of marriage
together and then your next the next day
and the day after that
and you got to put the work in every
single day
it doesn't matter how good things seem
heading into it if you're not willing to
put the work in every day then it's not
going to work out
uh and then the other thing that he says
that i that is a is a
another really important point that i'm
always trying to stress
is this idea of like having a sense of
adventure and i think that this was
advice directed particularly at men
it applies to women too but but i think
especially to men
having a sense of
adventure and that's the point about the
makes about you know have more kids than
you can afford take a job you aren't
qualified for the point is um it's not
to be reckless it's just to stop
calibrating and triangulating and
stalling all the time
which is what so many young people young
men especially that they waste
early adulthood young adulthood stalling
you know just waiting around
for a sign from heaven that now you can
move forward and actually live your life
at a certain point you got to jump in
and take some risks
yeah have a sense of adventure
which means like move out of the house
go do something
frustrates me to no end when i hear
these young guys
uh complaining even about you know well
there's no there's no jobs there's no
opportunities around where i live
or there
there are no people you know there's no
women there's no good women around where
i live with you there probably are but
you know you haven't looked hard enough
or you're looking in the wrong places
but whatever
okay even if that's true that moves
somewhere else
you're a young single guy if you're a
young single able-bodied guy
you have no dependents
you have no serious responsibilities in
life
now there could be some complicating
situations for some people maybe you
have an ailing parent that you can't
move away from okay if that's the case
for you then that's different but if
that's not the case if you don't have
anyone dependent on you
and you're young and single and a man
and you're able body then you can go
anywhere and try anything
just move go somewhere if it doesn't
work out go somewhere else
worst case scenario you get to work i
can't find a job i'll be okay so you're
living out of your car for a few weeks
whatever you're fine you'll survive
that's that's the adventure that's the
kind of thing that you know you do
things like that and you take risks
and then uh later on in life you those
are the kind of stories you tell your
kids and your grandkids
but i think for a lot of people they're
never to have any stories because like
they spent their 20s what are you going
to tell your grandkids about
all the time you spend in your mom's
house playing video games
you're not going to have any grandkids
anyway
so i think that's a great great moment
there from um
tucker carlson
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joy we're forming a cult then
all you gotta do is click the subscribe
button and ring the bell below uh this
video to stay up to date with all my
content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang